good morning everyone can you hear me so
well I mean thanks for showing up this
early I mean this is a kind of really
brutal time for a tutorial so but
anyways this I hope that this is an
interesting topic for you all so yeah as
as you heard i mean my name is villa
Tula's i work at a droll by the way i
mean like a droll will be having a booth
here so if you want to learn more about
what we are doing and like what we think
about things and especially if you want
to get one of these fine t-shirts you
will be able to do that tomorrow
somewhere here I guess so don't miss
that opportunity so anyway this is about
trail DB so first I mean this is
supposed to be a tutorial meaning that I
mean this kind of a I hope that this
could be a more like informal hands-on
session rather than like just me
speaking here like for an hour so and
oftentimes when i'm attending tutorials
I I find actually like a very slow but I
mean but I mean in this case actually I
wanted to kind of make sure that like
you can you can really kind of follow
all the steps so we are kind of going so
on purpose but if you feel that it's too
slow I mean you can actually find these
slides at this address so they should be
publicly available so it will so feel
free to kind of fast forward and start
like attacking whatever you feel like
hopefully using trial DB and and then
like feel free to ask questions anytime
so I guess actually we do have the mic
somewhere so if you have any questions i
hope that like we can use the mic and
and also there's the domain site for the
project is a trail DB that I Oh feel
free to go there feel free to browse the
documentation and like if any questions
come to your mind I mean you can you can
ask anytime about anything so don't
don't feel bad about interrupting the
flow of the presentation so and lastly
there's actually a cheater channel like
a check channel so that's going on all
the time so I mean feel free to join
that as well so we can definitely
continue chatting after this
presentation as well if you decide to
try these things at home what else oh
and there's a blink to github as well so
for the actual source code of course but
as I mentioned I mean this is supposed
to be a
tutorial so if you have a laptop feel
free to use it but in any case I was
planning to first spend maybe about
actually I can put the timer on about
like maybe first like a 30 minutes 20
minutes or so just introducing you to
trail debian like why we decided to do
something like this in the first place
so it's always a good question that why
you need something new ok um so um trail
DB is an efficient tool for storing and
querying series of events so basically
if you if we kind of a dissect this
statement a bit well trail DP that's a
nice name an efficient tool I I really
want to emphasize that this is a I mean
one of the things that you can use in
your toolbox in addition to all other
tools that you have been using this far
so and this is very company at least we
think that this is very complementary to
many other tools that are out there so
then I hope that like it will work very
well in in conjunction with all the all
the other things and then the next thing
the for storing and querying obviously
that kind of refers to the fact that
it's kind of a database so I mean like
this is about storing data and querying
data so that's that's kind of the theme
of this presentation but maybe the most
interesting point about this statement
is that it's really about very specific
kind of data so as i mentioned i mean
it's supposed to be complementary so in
that sense of course all of you probably
have been using some kind of databases
before like relational databases like my
sequin posters or maybe time series data
bases or maybe key value databases and
the point about 12 DB is that it's kind
of focusing on a slightly different set
of data as i will be as i will be
presenting soon so that's that's going
to really important point and namely the
kind of the day that we are talking
about today here is basically event data
like this so it can it could possibly
come from many different sources but one
of the most typical source sources are
44 like event based data like this is
users that's the users of way of your
web service or users of your mobile
application or or any kind of users
generating data and basically some kind
of events they do something so this is
like an example from web analytics tool
heap very very nice very nice
application
it shows that there was one user
actually using our dashboard at that
role and in this case you can see that
the user generated a stream of events
over time so at like two-thirty 9am they
viewed the campaign stage then they get
browsing the side and then they kind of
kept going to different parts of the
side over I guess what's that that's
like over like a four minutes of time so
basically you get the series of events
so that's a very very typical thing that
you can collect from from any kind of
application however it doesn't always
have to be about humans or like actual
users generating data it could be actual
machines like in this case for instance
this is like our infrastructure
monitoring from from AWS from amazon web
services and you can see that there's
one instance one server generating a
stream of events again over over
sometime saying that actually in this
case very boringly that everything is
okay but again I mean two series of
events and of course I mean to make this
a bit more exciting you could imagine
that this could be like a massive like
Internet of Things upset of like a tiny
little sensor so you could have a
million sensors generating these tiny
little events over time so so I mean
many many interesting sources of data
but the key thing I mean to note here
about the nature of this data is that
voila me first there is some kind of
some kind of an entity let it be user or
a machine generating the events and then
secondly there are this like a discreet
actions so that's really a key point
that like in this case the it this is
not about like tracking let's say the
stock price or like tracking temperature
or anything continuous of that nature
but this is a really about like those
different like discrete actions like it
like in this case this is actually an
admiral data showing that we record when
people browse websites we also show them
ads people click ads and so forth but
they are very distinct entities so so
they can't be tracked in a simple time
series as easily as you can track let's
say temperature or something of that
kind so that's that's really kind of
what i mentioned that trail dp's is
complementary so we feel that like kind
of at this very specific kind of data is
something that you
use more attention and I can maybe give
you a bit more context that like why why
we decided to start doing this symbol in
the first place so well I mean just to
give you a very like like a brief
introduction to do what a troll is doing
a troll is in advertising technologic
company meaning that we show people ads
which is a like if you look at companies
like Google and Facebook that's a that's
a kind of a obviously of like a very
important service in the economy but I
mean like givin the audience here I mean
why it is especially interesting is that
there's tons and tons of data involved
since so it happens that in consciously
the days of mad men this is not about
like having kind of a copywriter and a
design or a meeting with with the with
the companies and like to discuss about
their branding but this is solely about
looking at the data and understanding
from the data how we can actually show
ads to the right people at the right
time so they would actually end up
buying something so that's really the
core of the business so it's really
really all about data and actually like
what you can see in this visualization
here is interestingly that that
background noise I mean it's not just
like a pretty background picture
although it is that as well but it's
actually a data visualization so on the
y-axis we have different users actually
like different people surfing the web I
mean in this case it's about like if I
remember correctly about 200,000
different people and upon dentist in the
single visualization and on the x-axis
we have time so it's basically on the y
axis you have users on the x-axis you
have time and then it's going to hard to
see here but they are actually different
kind of colors so they are like tiny
little red dots that are ads so if
people feel that like you see too many
ads on the web that possibly can't be
true because it's really even hard to
see the ads here because they are so few
of them compared to everything else
what's happening so it's very sparse
also I mean you can actually dissipative
am in the x-axis is 24 hours in the
United States so if you look really
closely you can see that there is that
like a lighter like a like a clock in
the in the middle which is that kind of
the nighttime in the United States
offers a bit smooth and by the different
time zones
so people are surfing the web Atlas
actively so then the credits which is
most of the data are actually people
browsing different sides of their page
views and then the green line that you
can see is that like every night we
actually get some data dumps from from
external partners so that's kind of an
interesting looking stripe but basically
it is as you can imagine it is a lot of
data but I mean when you when you look
at this way I mean it's going too hard
to see that ok so is there any value in
this what's the point I mean it seems
like a cloud of dots but there's
actually a very simple transformation
that you can do so if you just take the
same data and you sort the rose so
basically just take this like a dot
cloud like a scatter plot and then you
to sort the sort of rose or like you
sort the y axis or the users what ends
up happening and and actually in this
case it's also sorted by account what
ends up happening is that like this
different kind of batter and immerse
emerge so it's not like just like a
uniform looking a random cloud of data
but actually there are all kinds of
things that you can start seeing and
like for instance I mean one thing
that's really obvious that lie to
different websites behave in very
different ways so you can see the tears
that like a very dark area which like
where response to the site where people
are really really engaged they produce
lot of data at that site innocent but in
some other cases it's totally opposite
and and like you can actually so um
actually maybe c0 yeah so you can
actually see that there's this like a
red area where you can start seeing that
like there's like really some accounts
that are actively showing ads to their
customers and and actually like what is
really really interesting also is that
it's kind of hard to see here it's like
down there you can actually see an area
where people or kind of these perceived
people never sleep so in many other
cases you actually see that like there's
less activity during nighttime but in
certain cases you see that the same
users keep bombarding producing data all
the time and actually the reason for
this is that these are not users at all
these are actual like boats they are
like there's like ad prod is a huge
issue in the
industry and like we're actively
fighting against it and and this is also
an excellent way to detect like very
anomalous like streams of events so if
something is behaving in a very strange
way you can usually start seeing it when
when you look at it the data this way so
the point being that light for a bad
role especially and like actually I
would claim that like for many other
companies as well and of course for many
others like a fields of research as well
being able to look at this kind of a
series of discrete events and being able
to analyze it efficiently it's very much
of a key question and again I mean just
to give you an idea of what kind of
things we do in practice so I mean just
to give you some background so like it
was mentioned in the introduction this
is an open source project that we open
source last May and but we have been
actually using a trail DB internally
like for two years so it's actually like
powering product it's a real deal and
and we are using it to for instance to
produce basic web analytics so you can
actually easily do things like a bounce
rate you can see how how like actively
people stay at the site but also more
interestingly you can start like a
inferring this kind of a causal
relationship between the ads and the
actions people take which can erase the
topic of like attribution models how do
you attribute the success of the ads to
the actual ads campaigns and then also I
mean like I mentioned the fraud
detection and then also we actually use
these things to drive features for
machine learning models so that's
actually a very interesting topic that
as you can imagine when you are building
predictive models open them it's very
interesting that like you can consider
it coin and you can actually divide if
ur enters over time so that's another
use case that we have had but as i
mentioned i'm in trail DB is a pretty
generic tool i mean it's definitely not
not specific to advertising or anything
like that so i'm sure that like you you
may find even more interesting use cases
for it now if you if you look at this
and that's a first like a very high
level as i mentioned it's like 24 hours
over 200,000 users so so now if you
imagine that like you zoom in a bit what
you basically start seeing is that you
can like look at things that at the
level of individual users so again I
mean like the
y axis is is users and the x axis is
time and now these users are producing
events discrete events of different
kinds and in this case they're just
different colors but um but the point is
that there are events that happen over
time and now quite simply I mean that's
that's in a way I mean all the trail DB
so we date this date and we package it
in a very simple very efficient file or
library to it like it like a database
file that allows you to slice and dice
them for it the data in different ways
and also I mean maybe like 11 more
important point is that um it's not only
meant for analytics or like a data
exploration it's also meant to be a
building block of actual production
systems so i will talk about this more a
bit later but I mean we feel that it's
also very important that the same tools
that you I guess many of you are data
scientist you used to do this kind of an
expiratory and like iterative
development to develop the models and so
forth is this you can actually use the
very same tools in production as well so
that's that's really kind of the point
so I mean now just to kind of a go a bit
deeper and like maybe a bit more
technical about really be so as I
mentioned I mean it's a very simple data
model the data model is based on the
fact that we have a some kind of a
primary key which is some kind of a user
identifier again I mean doesn't have to
be a user it could be machine whatever
but I mean there's some kind of a
primary key not actually in our case I
don't know if by now I mean like you
have checked the website or downloaded
the code or something you can see that
like just for convenience we assume that
like the the user IDs such as like a
16-byte you you IDs but I mean it's up
to you i mean what you want to use uses
the ids that seems to be a very I mean
like a like flexible enough format so
then like we have obviously these events
I mean what happened and when and then
it like importantly of course we have
the history of events so that's that's
kind of the whole point that like we
have all these three components so we
have the primary key to some user
identifier we have the events and like
that basically say that okay so what
kind of schema what kind of structure we
have for our data and then we have
basically history of these things and
just to put this in a context I mean
consider how this compares
other databases that you might have been
using before so for instance if you if
you think about like normal relational
database like post Chris or my sequel or
something like that typically what you
have is of course some kind of a primary
key you have your tables and the table
may have the primary key and actually
even at that role we have a table called
users and then there's the prefers the
user ID as the primary key of the table
and and in that table we we have a
column that's called last login date or
something like that and now every time
the user logs in we get an event saying
that the user has logged in and we
update the database we update the
Postgres database and the table to say
that the last login date is whatever is
there is a timestamp of the latest event
but the key point here is that of course
we lose the previous time stamp by doing
this and this is the nature of
traditional relational databases that
you make these destructive updates you
keep modifying the user's email address
you keep modifying whatever but I mean
whatever it used to be the previous
value gets lost and of course it is
quite possible to actually have a
separate table maybe that stores the
previous values but I'm that kind of
requires the extra work and that's
really not kind of a very fundamental
nature of relational databases so but I
mean as i mentioned i mean this is the
trail DB is very complementary not meant
to be of course like replacing
relational databases but really focusing
a slightly different use case then
another very interesting type of
database that maybe many of you have
been using before it is different kind
of time series data bases so for
instance we at that role are using a
tool called data dog to monitor our
infrastructure and what it does is that
it actually gets all these like a stream
of events and it then produces nice like
time series charge like showing let's
say cpu utilization or network
consumption or something like that over
a period of time and in this case again
i mean you can imagine that you have a
primary key that might be the let's say
the server ID the instance ID and now
you kind of get this history I mean you
have the time series of like let's say
the past like one day or like a one
month or whatever so in that sense in
this case you have the history as well
but however usually what happens with
time series data bases is that um you
that you are like aggregate the event so
instead of like storing every single
events every single recording of the cpu
utilization every second let's say you
aggregate this like what's the average
cpu utilization over let's say one
minute or 1 hour and so for it so in
that sense you kind of lose some
familiarity by doing that which is first
by design and totally fine but I mean
again I mean a slightly different animal
and then finally I mean if you consider
the case that like you basically just
keep logging data in log files which is
also something that we do at that role
and maybe many of you do as well you get
the history you get the very granular
events but I mean now of course like
querying data like this is quite tedious
so classically many many people may have
been using MapReduce do you run queries
over log files and many other things
like this but um but I mean it tends to
be pretty expensive and and not very
convenient so but in any case I mean
they're like surely many many different
ways of like storing data like this so
so why we need anything new I mean just
to give you some motivation what what
trail DB does differently well I mean I
mean I guess just like I'm happy to talk
more about this like maybe separately I
mean this kind of it like a passionate
topic for me but I mean one thing is
that like a developer productivity is a
big deal so so for instance a droll is a
smaller company we have about like a 50
60 engineers so I like productivity is a
really big deal overall I feel that like
it really makes a really a qualitative
kind of a difference when you are doing
especially data related work if the if
there's a very like a direct connection
between what you are thinking and the
ideas you might be getting and like the
models and then the tools that you have
so that the actual like the tools don't
impose any extra friction or like extra
time delay so anything like that in your
kind of a thought process so so overall
like we really want to have tools that
like make us very productive and like
don't hinder our thinking too much so
you will see soon I mean how we are
trying to accomplish that with with
Grady be another huge deal is that I
don't know if you have noticed but the
world is changing at least it has
changed since yesterday
I need in a more macro scale one big
thing that's happening is that like more
and more of computation and data related
stuff is moving to the cloud which is
for something that has been happening
for the past ten years already but
what's especially interesting if you
have been like for instance following
the announcements made by Amazon Web
Services over the past couple of years
is that even the servers are
disappearing so it used to be so that if
you had it like a MapReduce cluster you
had like actually we like back in the
day we used to have like good actual
like a physical racks of machines
crunching data and so forth and then of
course and actually like we used it like
a rack and stack the machines by
ourselves and that was kind of cool back
in the day but of course that's all past
I mean I hope that like no one has to do
it anymore and the next phase was that
like well you can launch this virtual
servers in the cloud and now you don't
have to physically kind of like hurt
your fingers bye-bye like rocking and
stacking the machines and at least you
can just click a button and get the
server but the thing is that you still
get the server and you still have kind
of like a cluster of servers running
somewhere and you have to worry about
that but like how many servers you want
then you want to have to worry about the
types of servers and so forth but
actually like like kind of what the
direction well the world seems to be
going is that actually you should be
really focusing on the actual
computation that you want to perform and
not the servers at all I mean at the end
of the day if you if you'd like for
instance considered typical things data
scientists need to do I mean it's really
there's very little about the servers
and like much about the actual
computation and like how this is
happening today is that like if you look
at like docker how much you can like
just package just docker containers
without having to worry about that the
host machine or especially something
like Amazon lambda that allows you to
just specify the function that you want
to execute and and like they will give
you a place to execute that function and
now I'm just quickly to give you some
idea why this is relevant to trail DB is
that um so it happens that like most of
the most of the kind of the classical
databases are based on the idea that you
have some kind of a very like a concrete
infrastructure you may have like a
database server or maybe you have
cluster of database servers and even
like a more modern like the key value
store each is likely say Cassandra or
HBase or something like that are based
on the idea that
you have some kind of a cluster that's
running this DCP be distributed database
but like if you don't have to worry
about clusters of any kind of like like
some fixed size for your computation why
should you worry about that for your for
your data either so the idea with the
trail DB is that like maybe the mindset
could change so that like you store
these pieces of data efficiently you put
them somewhere in the cloud you have
these functions that perform the
computation like on the pieces of data
that you care about and and like kind of
the idea of having some kind of database
machines this isn't that relevant
anymore and then lastly I mean another
big trend which you may have seen
happening in the database world overall
I mean like in the data tooling world as
well I step like kind of that you want
to focus on a certain domain it's very
hard to have like a one-size-fits-all
universal solutions actually it is often
times you get like a nicer tools when
you really focus on one one use case and
like that's the first what trail deep is
doing I mean by no means this is trying
to solve all problems we are focusing on
11 a very simple case and it actually
allows us to really solve that one case
hopefully better than many other more
generate solutions and then like really
I mean going under the hood and like
maybe this is the main point why you
should be interested about this I mean
in technical sense is that trail DB is
really based on the idea that you can
compress the data well and why it is
especially interesting of first many
there are many other tools out there
these days especially in the world of
columnar databases that allow you to
compress data well well so it happens
that especially data of this kind of
where you've imagined that the
visualization of having the users and
the y axis and the time on the x-axis
makes it arm more easy to compress data
like even more efficiently than what you
are able to do otherwise so just to kind
of give you some idea what it means is
that as you may know there's actually
like a very interesting very fundamental
connection actually between probability
theory information theory and and then
compression I mean that's there actually
like two sides of the same coin so the
whole point actually like going back
here
maybe the whole point of compression is
that you are able to predict and if your
data is totally uniform and you can't
understand anything about the data or in
the Indy extreme if it's really like I'm
produced by AAA like some kind of
fundamentally random process I mean
there's nothing you can do I mean you
can't compress date of that point
however if your data is more predictable
like in this case you can see that in
some cases if we know the account ID we
know that these users are more active or
in some other cases if we know that this
account is let's say based in Sweden and
they are browsing Swedish sites we can
actually leverage this to compress data
better so this is like really the kind
of dip the key point that we can
actually take advantage of the fact that
users are predictable we can take
advantage of the fact that things are
predictable in time if you look at the
short period of time I mean people
behave in or like any kind of entities
behaving in a pretty kind of consistent
manner at least for a short period of
time and also in other way around I mean
there's some things in the world that
are way more popular than others so if
you think of a concrete use case of like
like like looking at the web that
behavior i mean it's way more likely
that any one of you actually go to
youtube com then let's say a droll com
so we know that like you do be so is a
more popular thing and again I mean we
can leverage that in compression and
then of course well I mean this is what
all compression techniques do I mean
this is exactly what like Izzie zip does
and so forth but like why why this is
especially relevant for it really be is
that it like what r LD b does allows you
to compress the data and actually
perform interesting computation and
querying on the compressed data itself
without you having to decompress
something first and and why this is
important um it is it is really about
about speed so there is again I mean
there's a purse this kind of a classical
like a spacetime trade-off and the fact
that like the amount of data that you
can push through a let's say cpu core is
limited and so but i mean it means that
that's only about data so if you can
condense your information in a smaller
amount of bytes you can actually do more
computation in a time unit so this is
this is actually a funnily enough this
is a
a picture from a presentation that I
gave at the last PI data here in San
Francisco was a Facebook last time 2014
and I mean just give you an idea what
this shows is that on the y axis we have
the number of integer operations that
the CPU is performing by micro second
and then on the on the x-axis you have
basically kind of let's say that you
have some kind of a vector of certain
size of kilobytes and now what it shows
you I mean this kind of for illustrative
purposes what it shows you is that um if
your data is small enough like in this
case let's say 10 megabytes or so that
it fits in like l3 cache of the CPU you
can actually do amazing amount of
computation you can let's say go like do
like whatever 3.7 like it geko
operations per per second of ya for a
second and but I mean what happens if
let's say your data isn't quite as
efficiently encoded so if there's let's
say more redundancy and so forth it just
happens to be bigger and it doesn't fit
in the cache and there's some extra
delay caused by the fact that the CPU
has to fetch data from from ram well I
mean you kind of lose some efficiency I
mean like you whatever is the profit
goes from like a 3700 to 2500 or so yeah
please that's a that's a great question
oh yeah so yeah actually sorry let me
repeat the question so the question is
about the weather that compression stays
in a fixed sliding window so they're
actually not like a number of different
things that we do it is not exactly
based on a fixed sliding window so what
you can do is that like first I mean
maybe it's easier to explain after it
like going a bit more in detail but the
idea is that like we can look at
physical like that if you know like
basic run-length encoding so I mean same
person keeps doing the same thing I mean
however often that happens we can just
compress that very efficiently and and
then actually we also compress other way
around like I mentioned on the along the
y-axis so if many people keep doing the
same thing but um but it's a great
question and maybe in the end of the
talk we can we can talk more about the
details and actually if you are curious
you can go to the trail dbi your website
and there's less slightly longer
description about what would it how it
actually works so anyway so back to this
so so yeah so if the data is bit bigger
and like you you have to go in RAM I
mean then it's going to be kind of a bit
less efficient and of course I mean in
the kind of the worst case if your data
is bigger than what what fits in gram
and like you have to fetch it from local
disk or oh god for a bit i mean you have
to do some network operations i mean
then it's almost like game over and like
you have lost all performance so so
compression is the big deal I mean not
only for for for a space but also for
time which of course time corresponds to
productivity so you don't have to wait
so long so that's nice so okay so now we
are like trying to get to the I promise
that this will be more hands-on soon so
what is truly be in practice so first I
mean it's it's a very simple file so you
get the file so I mean I was actually
like really again I mean going back to
that I have simplicity simplicity and
productivity so I mean actually I'd
really like files especially immutable
read only files they are very simple to
handle you can put them on a USB stick
and give to a friend or you can upload
them in Amazon s3 and like it's it's
very easy to reason about what is
important is that like trail DB as I
mentioned in the first slide it is
really a library into libraries actually
implemented in C for performance reasons
but I mean in distance it's more like
something like sequel I'd or or many
other embedded
the basis maybe you have used leveldb
and but i mean very different from
postgres already's that are kind of some
like a standalone services that sits
somewhere and like you connect them to
like some network protocol and then so
basically like the idea is that the
trail v's is way more connected to your
application than these other databases
and again I mean I hear if I mentioned
it's really a read-only this a big deal
so which means that you can create these
things you can read these things but it
like you can't ever change these things
and I mean this may seem radical there
are many good reasons for doing this one
is that like actually for a type of data
analysis that we do actually this isn't
that much of a that much of an issue
since if you think that like we actually
do you want to analyze all the
historical data well I mean you could
argue that whatever happened in the past
can't change anyways I mean history
doesn't change so in this sense you can
kind of you can keep recording history
you can keep archiving history and like
then you analyze whatever happened in
the past but you don't have to change
what happened in the past of course you
just need to keep a pending stuff what's
happening right now so and going back to
the point of like the immutability it's
also related to productivity as well so
if you consider in python is like it
three different statements if you saw
this line of code somewhere so if you
see the first line i'm pretty sure that
like in the Python shell all of you know
that like what would be the result in
the second case it's harder to know but
I mean you can probably figure out quite
easily that like what's I mean you can
like just print a and print B and then
you can like find out what what should
be the result but I mean in the last
case like when you have some random
functions and the functions may be
calling google or facebook and you have
no idea what's going inside I mean
that's very hard to reason about and
especially they're not ed important in
the sense that like you may get a
different result every time you all
these functions so again I mean it's
very hard to know actually like build
systems around this idea of of light
constant like mutations so immutability
is also a big win in the productivity
point of view because when you know that
let's say you have a trail DB and unlike
it contains a set of data it won't
I mean if you kind of imagine something
like reproducible research I mean you
can kind of story that the data of your
study in a trail DB and you can share it
with everybody and light basically you
can take the md5 hash or whatever of the
data and it really won't change that's
actually surprisingly convenient another
thing is that this is of course the
Python conference so we are focusing on
Python here but in in practice actually
we do have many other language bindings
for trail DB as well so you don't have
to use Python and actually in many cases
there are cute reasons didn't know I
mean like this is of course like maybe
blasphemy in this conference but I'm
interrupt good reasons not to use Python
in some cases we support are actually we
support d I mean I don't know if anyone
cares here but I mean d is actually
surprisingly nice language for low level
of like a high abstraction programming
obviously see there's even like Haskell
binding and go these days as well so
many many different choices and actually
like Admiral is crazy enough to use many
of these languages in production because
so it happens that life like you want to
use right tool Photoshop and like in
different cases it is really like
justified to use something else then
let's say Python always or C so that's
that okay so okay so that was about the
first 30 minutes so no you can actually
if you are curious enough you can
actually try it for yourself I mean we
we can actually start by like just like
showing how are you can install it so
actually it should work on on OS X so if
you have a Mac left to laptop I mean it
should be okay also like different linux
distribution should work quite ok
actually as of yesterday night I don't
know if Oleg is here but he told me that
it also works on windows so that's
amazing so ok so what do you want to do
if you are on OS X is that you want to
open your shell and you want to do just
if you are using home proof so you can
do just like a pre-installed trail DP
that's by far the easiest way to do it
so actually I could
so actually I it's going to give but
this is really like literally what you
want to do
well anyway I have it installed so yeah
so I have it installed so so but I mean
then once you do that I mean you get the
thrill DP life right now that the key
point is that like we actually have the
land language bindings separately so
this is test the test the library itself
and it also gives you this convenient
command line tool of TDP so you can use
that to open open trolleybus and so
forth so that's what you can do on if
you have home proof then another option
is that you can clone the github repo
and then you can compile it from sources
it requires that you install a few
additional package cheese and like
actually alright so I don't have
connection here but anyway if you go to
github you they are like instructions
but you need to do on on OS X to get it
working so by the way if you have any
any questions we have like a few people
here like Oleg and enter it and I'm
great who can who can help you also if
you need help installing it so it really
shouldn't be too hard then on linux a
kind of its it's maybe like bit more
tedious so if we are using like a debian
based distribution or like you bundu I
me you can just do apt-get install and
install the dependencies they are like
not too many dependencies but it
requires so it actually uses sleep I are
currently Trudy and a package conflicts
so you want to do that or if the same
thing in rpm based distributions and
then like you want to clone it and and
then we are actually using this build
management system called Wafaa to
compile stuff so you can just write the
wolf configure and what install or what
built and and that should compile the
whole thing so it really shouldn't be
too complicated since I mean it doesn't
have too many dependencies and it's
rather simple library so yeah I mean
feel free to ask if you if you have any
any questions they're also if you go to
thrill DPI oh there's documentation and
there is like the getting started
section and and it has the same steps
and you can also of course look at these
slides
remind you about the address so if I
move forward to quickly you can even go
back in slides so
so for this for the examples i'll be
using linux but i mean it all should be
working the same way on OS X so that's
the installation there's unfortunately
like one small issue especially for
linux users that we are using this very
nice library called Judea race that's a
very efficient like like a mapping
structure for 4c unfortunately I mean
it's kind of like a perfect data
structure but it because it's perfect it
hasn't been maintained for reactively so
if you happen to have a like old version
of ubuntu or something and it complains
about version being too old you need to
fetch a newer newer one if you don't
want to put an upgrade your linux
distribution so for convenience we are
actually providing this library at the
site since i mean there seems to be a
frequently asked question so you can
actually just download the event of the
patched version of the library and you
can replace the existing one with that
light pre yeah go ahead sorry at the
point python bindings yeah the question
is about the Python 3 support there's
actually someone has been working on
that so good question so let me know I
mean like how it works with Python 3 we
have been using 2.7 I mean there
shouldn't be many things I mean mainly
like related of course this string usage
that you may face yeah hopefully
hopefully kind of coming soon yeah so
that's that's about the installation so
then like when you when you have the
thing installed what you can actually do
is that there's a like a test tralee be
included in them in the kind of the
source repo so it's called test so i can
show you so maybe here so actually i
have here like well if we go to trail DB
and we let's say just focus i guess i
have all kinds of things but I mean you
should find in the trail DB report there
is a thing called test TDP
and it's just a very simple kind of a
sanity check that everything works so
what we can do is that we can actually
use this DDP command line tool 22 DDP
dump which basically shows you the
contents and you can give dash I for the
inputs and you can say test and you
should see something like this so if you
have it like working installation
especially if you have done just the
prove install on your OS X and then you
have cloned the github repo me you
should be able to just the right this
exact thing and you should see something
like this I mean to make it a bit
fancier actually what you can do is that
you can like do dash a and it gives you
Jason and then if you have one of the
like typical Jason utilities on the
command line you can do shake you and
then you get this like a very pretty
printed version of the same thing and so
basically this shows that it actually
works it's able to open the trail DP and
things are good so hopefully you are
able to do that I me feel free to ask if
you have if you have trouble getting
this for ya
that probably means that like you are
it's not finding the the library so are
you in the trail DB directory so you may
need to do the CD trail DB so it should
be in the same you should find this like
a test dot tdb in the directory where
you are so i have i have it here and
then when you do this I think like if
you if you do something like that yeah I
mean then you get the error because it
can't find it I mean could be actually
more descriptive but yeah also if you
forget the dash all you may get the same
thing right so you want to have the dash
I
right so anyway so that's that shows
that your installation works so maybe
let's let's move on to the next thing so
basically what you see here first this
looks let's see the fancier version this
may not look like much but I mean what
you really see here is that like you see
except the things that we have been
talking about so you have some kind of a
user ID you have some kind of a time
stamp and you have some event in this
case so basically this guy here is one
event for for this uuid for this user I
mean it happened at this time and it
just happened to say hello world this is
obviously dummy dummy data so I mean
nothing nothing too interesting but I
mean it's really kind of showing things
in this trail DP format or the data
model so now I'm kind of a testing the
hello world is very rewarding by itself
I mean things work so now we can
actually start doing something slightly
more interesting so there's actually a
kind of a slightly bigger thrill DP that
I created for this tutorial so you can
actually find it at this address so if
you just download that file so its trail
dbio / data / PI data dash tutorial TDP
and you can actually then do the same
thing leave it there for a minute so um
what it actually contains is that it has
data from Wikipedia so if you go to the
actually light you don't have to do it
now but I mean like if you go to 12 ebi
oh and you open the documentation and
likely receive also tutorial the
tutorial is actually based on this
Wikipedia data so interesting thing
about Wikipedia is that they provide
historical logs of every single edit
operation that um that has ever happened
in the Wikipedia so it's actually very
interesting data sets if you imagine
like how wikipedia has been evolving
over time and it's also quite sizeable
data so i guess wikipedia has been
around for
no in more than 10 years at least and
and they of course they have recorded
everything so if you actually like
there's if you go to trail dbio and
documentation you can actually find a
link to a trail DB that's about five
foot eight gigabytes I didn't want you
to download that because we would be
probably like it like a DDoSing that the
Wi-Fi here um but um this is a smaller
version of the same data a smaller
sample of the Wikipedia data but you can
also download the full dump of all
wikipedia edit since since the since the
beginning of time as one trail DP and
that one trail DB is five point eight
gigabytes and why this kind of
interesting is that as i can actually
maybe show you now the data we have here
if I do the PI data tutorial the data we
have in this database looks like this so
basically you have some kind of a user
identifier for the user who made the
edit in Wikipedia and then you have a
timestamp for that edit and then you
have a title of the wikipedia page where
the Edit operation happen and then
actually like at least in the past
Wikipedia allowed anybody to make edits
without logging in so we have a username
for the user who made the edit but I
mean in some cases let's see if we have
an example I guess there are like just
this one guy has been doing a lot well
maybe
yeah i mean like here so you can
actually see that like in the case is
when we don't know the username of the
person who made the Edit we know the IP
address so there's either the username
or we have the ID at her so we can do
interesting things based on that but the
interesting thing is that there have
been about like the 600 million edit
operations in Wikipedia between I guess
like a 2000 something and then like I
guess I did this last May this isn't the
last May or so so it's about 600 million
events in the trail DB and it's about
five point eight gigabytes which means
that like we use about nine bytes to
store each of these events so i guess
that speaks to do the kind of thing kind
of the efficiency of the compression
that like we can store the title of the
idiot and we can store the IP address
and we can store the username and the
time stamp which by itself is actually
64 bits or eight bytes in just nine
bytes so it is it is actually
surprisingly compressible and
predictable but it also means that i
just think about it that like you can
download actually you can really do it
right now if you are curious enough you
can download the whole history of
wikipedia to your laptop and if you
happen to have 8 gigabytes of ram on
your laptop you can basically take the
whole history of wikipedia in the ram of
your machine and you can start doing all
kinds of things with that data and
that's really amazing and that really
relates to the question of productivity
that like you don't need any you don't
need like a cluster of machines you
don't even need a server you don't need
anything fancy and you can stop just
start tinkering with the data which is
extremely powerful ok so hopefully maybe
by now i mean like you have found this
data set so we will be using this for
for a few examples um so and i just did
kind of it give a bit more light about
this concept so basically again I Minh
Trail is the list of events there's the
unique ID so there are these different
fields so I can show you here so you
have the time and title and user and IP
would be different fields and and that
those different fields basic which
defines the scheme of your data that
defines one event and every event has a
time stamp but and then like every event
relates to a single user but all the
other fields are up to you you can
define them to be whatever you want but
you have to define the money or trade
tradie be okay so how do you how do you
like make data of your own so actually
like if you happen to have some like
like proprietary data or like data you
have been using in the past I mean you
can definitely by all means use it I
mean you actually like follow follow
this tutorial so I mean it's actually
quite simple so all you need is some
kind of unordered stream of events so I
mean you don't have to do much any
pre-processing beforehand all you need
is some kind of a like user ID that you
can use as dead as the uuid and
timestamp up actually like we are always
using time stamps in the country unix
timestamp format it actually it can be
at like whatever crandall read it can be
even like acted like a microsecond dorm
in the second level it's up to you well
I needs to be 64 bits but usually I mean
you can suss take the second level unix
timestamp and then you can have whatever
feels you want so and how it works is
that like we can actually just for
simplicity we can use the command line
tool at first to create a trail DB so
what you can do is that you can just
create a test file like a CSV file and
what you can do is that like you can
actually like for convenience you can
actually define the fields in the header
of the CSV file so you can say that my
first column is the uuid the second
column is time and then you have you can
come up with some fields and and then
you come up with some values for those
fields I can show you how it could look
like in practice so
so if we had a file like this a very
simple file you can actually use a
different delimiter so if you want to
use commas but I mean spaces work in
this case and what you can do now is
that you can say TDP make and you can
give that file like let's say this csv
and now you can also say that like okay
so this file includes the CSV header so
that first line if you didn't have that
you could actually say fields and then
you could give the same list but I mean
for convenience if you know that you
have that theorem you don't have to do
it so you can subscribe to CSD header
and then like we can give it give it
some name did I specify some name here
is my test we can try that of course
so okay so it created that but I mean do
we know that it actually worked so what
we can do again is that we can do the
dumb thing and like we can see how it
looks like first it's not my test right
and and again let's make it prettier
like this so now you can see that
magically that CSV file here transformed
into these two events in trail DP so it
works I mean maybe very exciting but
that's the basic principle the beauty of
this is that you could actually have
like a really massive CSV file and and
this should be pretty efficient so I
mean you can you can hopefully handle
even like a gigabytes of data on your
laptop without trouble if not more and
actually like you can also define the
inputs s like JSON objects so often
times let's say if you are using
external web services or something like
that to collect data your data may be in
Jason and actually you can do the same
make operation using Jason as well so if
you can actually maybe find some
financed by just like looking at the TDP
usage instructions okay so yeah yeah so
you need always you need uuid endpoint
they don't have to be the first field so
you can actually have any kind of
especially if you have chosen I mean and
be anything and they don't have to be
called that but yes you need to have
some kind of EU you at the end time so
okay
so now I mean hopefully uh we can both
read trail db's and create really busy
using the command line well now of
course this Python conference so
hopefully we can do something in Python
and actually what you want to do next is
that you want to install python bindings
which come in in a separate repo so like
I mentioned we have many different
findings so the bindings are like
maintained separately so hence you have
to kind of go through this extra step so
you can actually flown that trail DP
Python it's a very simple it's actually
like basically one file and it's you use
the normal setup that py to install it's
system wide but I mean you don't even
have to do that if you don't want to
install it system what you just have to
stand set your pythonpath the point of
tea at the trail db5 and directory
and like I mentioned and this has been
tested on well at least Python 2.7 I
have no reason to believe that it
wouldn't work on like 2.6 and that so
forth but might be some like rough a
cheese if you are using Python 3 I guess
if you were using Python 3 you would be
listening to the other tutorial most
likely anyways
so I have done these steps previously so
I can just like to show you that the
once you have done the github cloning
you get this thrill DB Python and
actually thirsty that's basically the
file that we care about so the setup
that py installs that due to fear like a
system Pat's but I mean you can just set
pythonpath like something like this
really the Python poison and then Troy
DB that should work if you don't want to
install anything so feel free to ask if
you have any any trouble with these
steps and I hope that it's pretty please
so okay so now we can actually get to
actual Python code so now I mean in this
very first example which you can
actually find in the examples directory
of the of the Python repo so you don't
have to type it from this slide you can
actually just look at this file and it's
actually the same example that's also in
the documentation at thrill dpto this
example just basically create something
dumb and simple I'm similarity to the
previous example with the CSV so the
important point here is that they're
actually like two main objects in the
Python binding we have this thing called
trail DB constructor which is the thing
you want to use when you are creating
neutral db's and then there's the trail
debating which you want to use when you
are opening existing stuff and I mean
it's really not nothing too complicated
but few things to keep in mind first is
that when you initiate this thrill DB
constructor you need to give it some
name which becomes the name of the file
you don't need to add the dot TVB just
come up with some name and then kind of
this defines this scheme up so this kind
of the important part that like you need
to basically announced in advance that
like what feels you want to have in your
data now actually like may begin
contrast kind of relational databases or
and so forth so actually these fields
are like really pretty cheap so and like
three DB works really really well with
sparse data which of
x real time like a real world data is so
I mean you don't have to feel bad about
like just like adding a long list of
fields and like even knowing that many
of them will end up being empty or
something like that so they don't really
add much overhead since basically that
stuff gets compressed away so but anyway
you have to come up with some list of
deals in advance then in this exam
that's it so I mean for this that's it
for this really be a kind of the
immutability part here so the question
was if you can change the fields later
but I mean like for the for the 120 be I
mean when you create it you define the
fields and you can change it for that
late for that really be later so but of
course the actually like what ends up
happening practice I mean just to give
you some like a real world example we
have like kind of like a one mastered LD
be at that role that we are using for
many different use cases and of course
over time we have been actually like
updating the thing I mean like kind of
death like like kind of a schema let's
say like over the past two years and
like of course we always come up with
new things we want to record so we have
been just adding them and and unlike we
actually create this trail db's kind of
the daily cabin so every day we create a
new trail DB so basically one at some
point we just add new fields and and
then the previous ones in the history
they didn't have this thing we weren't
collecting that piece of data before but
then they kind of at some point I mean
this field appears and then typically
all Cory's I mean just noticed at well
at some point in the past the Yukons
just basically use that field but I mean
then you can add it ready at some point
yeah so I mean in this case we assume
that like you don't have any any data of
course in practice most often what you
would be doing let's say even in your
Python program that will be reading the
data from some external source in this
case we assume that like we just
generate some data on the fly in this
case what we do is that we take we come
up with three users we generate some
like a random uuid for them using the
uuid library in Python we come up with
some random username and now I mean just
kind of a for the examples sake we
assume that these users are performing
some actions and in this case let's say
that they perform like three different
actions they open something save
something and close something and again
I mean then we come up with sometimes
for these events and and then we add
them in in Tralee be by calling this
cons object con sad and then we say that
okay this thing is related to this uuid
now an important thing is that actually
these don't have to be in order so you
could kind of a produce the stream of
events like four different people like
kind of producing data at different
times in any any order so an antral DB
will go and sort them but I mean in this
example I guess they are pretty much in
order and then the important interesting
thing is that when you are done adding
stuff you have to call this thing called
once finalized which basically tells
trail DB that like now I'm done adding
all events in this really be and now I'm
done and you can basically actually
compress the data and I'm create the
file so you always have to call this
thing when you are not planning to add
more events to district DB in practice
again I mean what typically happens is
that you you may produce these things in
kind of Apaches or micro batteries that
you take I'd say one hour worth of data
and you create one trail DB then you
finalize it and then you start a new one
or if you have more like a static data
set you do it only once so I can
actually show you I should have the I
should have the same code here like
shows up quite nicely um and now what
happens let's see if we can actually I
guess I was here before so I can do this
create yeah I mean it doesn't print
anything but i guess i was calling it
tiny DDP so i can see that like
something but created and now if we see
what went inside you can actually see
that like the for loop came i mean there
there was the random uuid a soda the
third their son like uuid then we
produce this like a dummy timestamps
there are the usernames and and then
these are the dummy actions but now you
have this like a beautiful beautiful i
like a trail DB containing different
events for different users and actually
as you can see in this output kind of
all results related to a single user or
like consecutive so I mean that's like
ordered here although they might not be
ordered
in the input itself so that's how you
can create stuff in Python quite simple
so now actually like reading is it may
be even simpler so all you have to do is
yeah that's correct you can't so
basically what you want to do is that
you can add a new construction like you
can but I mean after you call finalize
you can't use that cons object anymore
sorry that's correct you yeah the
question is that like if you if you can
like add stuff in the index rill DB or
the constructor after you call finalized
and the answer is no you can't and and
you contact later so again I mean the
idea is this like how how we end up
using it is kind of like a append only
thing that like you append this like a
chunks of data I'll be maybe talking
about that bit later but but I yeah I
mean like for that chunk of data i mean
that's done and finalized so and the
idea is that the enemy history doesn't
change so yeah so about like reading so
I mean that the reading part is pretty
simple all you have to do is to import
the trail DB object and and then you say
that okay what's the thing you want to
open its to kind of let's say or a tiny
thing and then there is this very
convenient method all trails that
actually gives you an iterator overall
individual users are over all individual
trails in the trail DB and what it gives
you is the uuid and it gives you an
iterator over the trail as well so and
then we can print this out so let's see
again again like right this is the piece
of code here and and now let's see like
when we execute it looks actually like
pretty ugly since ah there's the uuid
here and i use the list so you can see
that there are these like event tapas or
name topples actually in Python um you
can see that life for every event object
you have time stamp you have again the
user name and and in this case obviously
it's all grouped by buy it by the user
it's easier see this way so we have
three users and they have
trail of events and they're really the
kind of a one thing to note is that like
why I call the list there so if we do
this on and then we call it you can
actually see that like it gives you a a
cursor so it's actually not a list of
events and this is actually an important
point so by default when I did the
trails what it does is that it actually
iterates over every trail in the trail
DB and now imagine that if you had
downloaded let's say that dump of the
full Wikipedia history I guess they have
about like a 40 million different users
so in Python like really definitely what
you don't want to do is to basically
kind of a produce a list of like a 40
million users and like a list for every
event so basically if you imagine that
data is like the five point eight
gigabytes compressed I mean if you load
it in Python I mean it would be
uncompressed at least 10 times plus the
Python overhead so we would be talking
about hundreds of gigabytes of a peep
that Python would be consuming so that's
not a good idea but I mean what what you
can do instead with trail DBS you can
actually lazily kind of iterate over
everything and like then you only like
process the parts that you want or you
aggregate some summary statistics so you
don't have to have like a massive
amounts of memory to handle everything
so basically you can iterate over the
different trails and of course you can
also iterate over individual trail so
that's why you get the cursor and not
the list of events so you can like
basically lazily keep only interesting
in the amount of data and of course you
can use all the beautiful tools in
Python like eater tools to slice and
dice the different the trail in
different ways so but I'm it's all all
like lazy lazy traitors that you get
well obviously I mean you don't have to
always like a scan things through
sequentially you can also hope to an
individual ID and how that works is that
again at me when you open open the trail
DB you get the handle to tdb and now you
can either look up things by and if the
row ID or the trail ID so basically if
you have three rows you have like a
basically 2012 so you can you can
basically say that I want this trail ID
and that's super fast
operation but also of course if you know
that you do ID and this may be more
typical use case let's say you actually
had a like a like a web service using
trail DB and like someone like makes an
API call and gives you a google uuid and
says that ok I'm on things related to
this guy then you would actually use
this thing called thing called like get
uuid to get that like ah oh sorry I mean
like you would actually like like just
like put the uuid here and like you
would you would then like a get to trail
related to that you you I did then
actually there's the operation that
given the role ID gives you the uuid
there's also like a convenient operation
to to check that like if a uuid exist in
the trail DB so you can you can like do
the sanity check if you want and yeah so
this way basically you can you can hope
to roast that you you care about well I
mean I'm sure that you can imagine how
it looks like so maybe I don't need to
show that then they are like some like a
kind of a bookkeeping basic metadata
operations like that you need so you can
imagine that the occasional you want to
see the fields you can do that if you do
Len and TD be what you get is you get
the number of trails basically a number
of rows or number of users and the trail
baby you can get like a minimum and
maximum time stamps in the trail DB by
calling time range if you do parse time
it actually gives you datetime objects
in Python and not that unix time stamps
and like one thing that's like really
convenient often times is that um you
can use these lexicon operations to
actually see distinct unique values for
different fields so you can ask that ok
so if i have the username field what are
the like well let me first how many
distinct usernames i have and also i
mean you can actually iterate over all
users that exist in this trail DB so and
well
yeah that's separate so that dope right
so I guess here so these study the
operations and let's see so i guess like
these are the fields the next one is the
number of trails then we have the first
time stamp and the last time stamp and
then we have let's see actually
interesting lead is actually a good
point so so when when i do the lexicon
size it actually gives you four and like
these are like for the username but they
actually like you can see only three
usernames so there's always a special
like a null or empty value so like I
mentioned I mean often times data a
sparse so there's I for every field you
have like TT empty string as a special
case so in that sense I mean it like you
can see like a three non-empty usernames
plus the empty one which is not listed
here so it's just for so those are the
basic kind of a metadata operations so
actually now kind of getting to
something more interesting so of course
if you consider it like a normal
database usage what you do with like
relational databases like almost never
you scan through the whole database but
you actually are interested only in the
subset of the events let's say so like
you do select something where and that
we're close is actually what you can do
with the event filters so you can get
only a subset of filters and in the
interest of time maybe I will kind of go
quickly through the idea so what you can
do is that basically you can actually
define a boolean query so you can say in
this case you can have a very simple
case that like you say that okay give me
only events that have action open and
then gives you only those events but i
mean like i mentioned i mean this
actually looks operating a kind of
actual like a boolean queries that are
expressed in this like a conjunctive
normal form which means that you can be
also unions you can say that like action
equals open or action equals close but
that's like or and then you can
obviously do and sis well and that if
you actually like a bit look closely the
point is that like one list here is
basically like one Union and then if you
give it two lists so in this case you
have the two separate lists in a list
then basically it's a kind of a list of
unions that are separated by an and it's
kind of the idea of the conjunctive
normal form and so you can basically
construct the query in a pretty kind of
a like a concise format like this I can
and then lastly I mean you can of course
do you negations the negations maybe
mitt looks been a bit funny maybe but
the idea is that like there's this flag
gold like is negative and you can say
that yes I this guy is negative so you
can say that it should be true so I can
like just quickly maybe show you so
again on let's take I guess that's the
simple case let's say let's say the
Union so it's the same guy so we are
interested only in the events that are
ready to action open or action flows and
now if we if we look at this maybe you
actually it might be easier if we don't
bring the uuid not that relevant here so
you can see that light there are only
opens and close and I guess we had to
save event as well so it gives you gives
you only those events and like well I
mean of course again this might not seem
like much but actually what's really
important about this desperately in
terms of python is that this is
implemented in the c library itself so
instead of you doing this in Python you
can upload this writer kind of them may
be expensive operation to the library
and it actually only get the data in
Python that you want to analyze the game
coming to the point that that are you
you kind of a pythoness of personal
performance so you want to minimize the
data you want to handle on that side so
now actually this is um maybe they're
kind of the most exciting part so I
showed you before that visualization
that was created using using a drove
statham you can actually like do that by
yourself right now it's actually like
really really cool and and why it is so
cool is that actually there's this very
nice package in the Indiana condo
ecosystem call data shader I highly
recommend taking a look there's a like
really nice presentation about data
shader and why it is useful and
it's actually especially a very good
match for something like really be that
allows you to handle large amount of
data very easily so so i guess like
there was some lee instruction that you
should have anaconda installed on your
laptop where you came here so there are
actually instructions for that and given
that this is kind of conference is
closely related to the whole like a like
a numpy ecosystem or like a PI data
ecosystem self if you haven't done it
yet there will be many opportunities to
be that later but if you have it so you
can do just Conda installed understand
data shader and in the interest of time
um I can just like a quickly give you an
example I mean this is this is all there
is to this example and so what we are
doing here is that we are using the
using the de Wikipedia example that I
gave you earlier and the again I mean
the Wikipedia was about edits done on a
Wikipedia and what we are doing in this
case actually it's a fun little example
is that unfortunately as you may know I
mean like the the artist Prince died
last April I guess and and of course
there is the page about Prince in
Wikipedia and unlike we might be
interested in knowing how like princes
and if popularity has changed over time
and like how how his death might show up
in Wikipedia since of course as you can
imagine every time something big happens
in the world I mean people are crushed
to update Wikipedia so what we can do is
that we can actually um use the event
filter to say that okay give me only
actions that are related to the princess
Wikipedia page in the end up in the
trail DB and then in this case we are
basically are likely trading over every
every user assuming that maybe they have
done something related to Prince I mean
we are only taking the Prince related
events and then like for every event we
are actually like in this case yielding
at the time of the first event and then
the events themselves by the way I mean
you can find this example also in the
trail DP Python repo under data shader
example and and then what we are doing
with this data is that we are like
taking basically creating this array of
points so we have like x axis
x axis and we have y axis and the x axis
act is again time we normalize the time
by the first time stamp in the database
and then the y's are basically says that
the user ID so it's just basically like
every rogue gets it own sequential ID
and then in this case we actually want
to have like two different types so we
like i mentioned i media allows both and
in the mouse and like registered yet
it's so it we have two types or animals
or registered and then like once we have
these x and y points we can actually add
them in a pandas dataframe so data
shader operates on unpunished data
frames so we act the x and y there and
then we also add this like last
categorical column in pandas here and
then we return the whole data frame from
this get data frame thing and then this
is actually the data shader part so what
the data shader does is that it allows
you to basically kind of a built this
massive like well they are not quite
scatter plots but basically plot your
data in in in a very kind of like raw
format and then it takes care of
actually rendering the points in such a
way that like it tries to kind of make
the day that like still i mean like kind
of a retained the kind of the important
aspects of data since like i mentioned
in my earlier example we had about
200,000 users basically 200,000 points
kind of on the on the y-axis but
obviously that the image itself wasn't
like it two hundred thousand pixels so
whenever you have to you have to do some
like a sampling there and that's what
data shader does for you and then we
also saying that like we map these
anonymous users the red color and and
the users do the blue color and then we
output that to add PNG and actually like
what it would look like is this so you
can see that like you have users again
on the old y-axis time on the x-axis and
interestingly well I mean this is since
the beginning of Wikipedia suggested
timestamp is something like 2,000
something and and this is actually April
here or April May here and actually
interesting what you can see is that um
most of the activity on the princess
paige happened I don't know maybe around
like a two thousand five to two thousand
times something like that maybe if one
of you is a fan of kiss you may know
that maybe he was publishing more
recordings at that time or something
more exciting happened but
is a lot a lot of activity there and you
can see that there are lots of red dots
corresponding the anonymous edits and
some like blue kind of the stripes
meaning that there were some like maybe
dedicated fans who kept editing the page
over time and then like what's really
curious is that then you see this line
here which is when he died so you see
that like there was like kind of a rush
of edits happening exactly on the same
day on the page when everybody came in
and and wanted to chime in I guess so
that's that's pretty interesting view to
the data still again I mean you see the
same defect that it kind of looks like a
big cloud of dots what you can do is
that um you can just add this like one
little thing here which basically says
that like since we output the first edit
time here we can actually just call sort
it and it sorts by this thing here and
and basically meaning that like let's
sort the rows of the visualization by
the time of the first edit and let's
just have it in the reverse order so
that's this small modification but the
visualization looks way more interesting
so now what you can see here is that
like early on when Wikipedia wasn't that
popular I mean there wasn't that much
activity I mean maybe for the fourth
like the first some years some prints
fans created some page but really little
activity then at some point what's that
it happening is that there was like a
lots and lots of like and the most users
making edit so you see this like a red
stuff and then the blue guys as well
doing stuff over time and interestingly
at some point the I just I don't know
exactly how the dynamics of Wikipedia
work but at some point they stopped the
anonymous edit so the red dodge stop
totally and of course since most of the
ideas were in animals I mean then the
kind of the volume of edits decreased
also quite a lot and now when you
actually look at this you see that the
edits that like in the previous
visualization was kind of hard to see
that like how many people actually
created this edits it's going to be
easier to see that like it's actually
well i mean first I mean what is really
noticeable here is that these guys who
actually made the edits on the under on
the day of death actually hadn't made
that many edits before so which means
that they were actually new users who
just knew that some like a notable
person died and they wanted to make the
edits but they really didn't care about
prints that much
although I mean there are some like
dedicated fans who also made some edits
oh but I mean there's like a lot of
information condensing this
visualization and all it took this is
this like a and if it maybe 30 lines of
code so again I mean like you can
definitely like to play with all kinds
of things here I mean change the colors
do and of course by all means I mean
especially if you take the full dump off
the old Wikipedia history there's like a
tremendous amount of exploration that
you can do there so that's that's very
cool and I know that we are like kind of
running shorting time so let me just
quickly touch some kind of a more
advanced topics so one is about
performance so obviously like if you
especially consider the full Wikipedia
example of 600 million events and like
40 million users I mean like you are
really kind of stretching the limits of
Python that's really a lot of data but I
although I mean the trendy be by itself
is something that fits in RAM so they
are like a few performance tricks that
you can do while still using Python well
I mean just to give you an idea so
basically how it really works internally
is that like every field has that like a
lexicon set of values that are stored in
a separate place and but what's really
important is that actually internally it
handles everything as integers so which
are called items and one item is
actually a combination of one field and
one value so these are the items in
trail DP internally and in contrast in
many other databases trail DB actually
doesn't hide these internal details
totally is there really important in
performance point of view so we actually
have a set of functions in the poison
binding that allows you to convert back
and forth between the strings and
integers and and why this is important
is that um well first internally I mean
like it's it's way more efficient to
handle just integers that streams
especially since in the case of trail d
beta streams can be any binary data you
can even store images or utf-8 whatever
so it's going to complicated topic
strings overall but more importantly um
it's actually like just way more
efficient even in Python to handle
integers and strings so let's say that
we wanted to know that like what are the
most common pages in Wikipedia so I mean
now this is actually like that may be
the simplest way of doing it oh so you
open the trail DB you have the counter
object in Python it's very
convenient you just iterate over every
single trail every single event you add
all the titles in the counter and the
culture has a nice like a most common
operation so it gives you the top five
titles in Wikipedia super nice but the
problem is that it actually has to of
course the titles are strings so now you
can imagine that like every time you
just like account like one event you
have to kind of take the string and
honestly I mean for counting the
statistics doesn't make a difference if
you are using string so integers so
actually this way more efficient to do
the statistics based on the integers
like in this case you can do that by
saying roll items equals true and you
basically collectors that is text using
integers and then only in the end once
you have the top 5 you convert them the
strings you get exactly the same output
but the fact is that it's all almost all
over twice as fast as the string version
so it's got a bit like a something that
something that like we kind of a want to
make things easy with Python like this
is a first is super easy version but I
mean occasionally you kind of want to do
a bit more to make it like a lot faster
and then this is kind of way how you can
do it they're actually like many other
things like really lots of things we
have really concerned about performance
it because of size of our data so
there's in the documentation you can
find this like a performance based
practices which gives you all kinds of
three tricks especially for lower level
language is how to make things fast so
that's that and now as the last topic I
want to touch yeah I have to touch the
question of overall architecture so this
is going to be super quick we can
actually talk about this later maybe so
I mean one which we touched already is
the question of starting so especially
if you have a continuous data stream
what do you want to do is that like you
want to keep creating trail db's as over
time you kind of a pen neutral DP what
we do is that we do it every day so you
can start it by time but also I mean you
can start it by users so another good
use cases that you just like maybe use
some hashing function to decide that
these users go to this side and these
users go the other side or it could be
based on any other field as well or you
can do both actually you can have like a
whole matrix of things which is
convenient if you have a lot of data
then another big question I guess
someone asked that already is about like
how do you actually do this in a d
if you're exciting or of course you
can't do everything in your laptop so
well i mean first one thing that like we
really think is totally undervalued in
the Big Data community is how much you
can do on a single server so and they're
like like really like innumerable number
of benefits in just like using a single
servant I mean one of them is that it's
the super productive and easy to debug
and like easy to develop on and all that
stuff so this is actually like a like an
example from like one massive like a
machine learning tasks that we are
performing using trail DP at that role
what we do is that um this is a single
server like a t28 extra large is a
massive server with 244 gigs of ram and
I guess like a 40 terabytes of this 48
spinning disk so it's perfect for
sequential I Oh what you can do is that
you spend some time downloading trail
db's from history then you actually have
it like a multi-threaded or like
multiple processes processing the data
so you do the processing I'll actually
here like you like read the trail DBS in
memory then you do the processing and
then when you are done you upload the
results in history and this is actually
like not taking too long this is the
single server it's actually very
convenient and and like especially when
you have a multi core server given that
like trail dps are immutable it's very
easy to do multi-core you just open a
trail DB handle in every let's say you
can use a multi processing module and in
Python or you have multiple threads so
keep that in mind I mean often times you
don't need actually a cluster of
machines however like one actually
there's a separate presentation that we
have given about this so I don't I don't
spend too much time on this but really I
mean a droll is actually using AWS for
everything so the whole business runs on
AWS so of course when we designed to
really be we really designed it in in
AWS in mind and how it works in our case
is that like we have a separate master
data store which is actually also in s3
where we just like a dump this basic
clock pulse like CSV then we have a
process that like produces trail DB is
given these logo files and the trail
db's are dumped in amazon history and
and now what is really really nice is
that like amazon s3 is like one of the
greatest things ever built by the human
point so it's massively scalable really
reliable so what are you can use that
you can have an arbitrary number of
conceived
worse than taking the trail Davis from
history and performing different kind of
computation on the trail deepest and
this is really really nice and a robust
and scalable architecture and like one
thing to know this series that we really
don't have to ever worry about the size
of your database class throw the expense
of your queries or anything like that is
all you have to do is basically scale
the number of machines based on the on
the type of the computation you want and
then you just copy the trail DPS to as
many places as you need and how we do
this at that role there's a separate
presentation actually like we define
this like a data dependency craft using
using this Python package called Luigi
that has been actually a nice
presentation about this apply data
before we have a blog article and number
of presentations about this so feel free
to go to our detector that'll calm you
can find articles about this and and we
package these different data processing
jobs as docker containers and then we
have a nice auto scaling probe that
basically gives us as many spot
instances as many machines as we have
been to need to perform the computation
so all in all what you get is this I
basically elastically scalable like
unlimitedly scalable computation
environment where you can like define
your jobs as a simple docker containers
I mean which means that you can use any
language some jobs are in Python we even
have jobs within in our in production
something stuff written in C I mean it
all works beautifully in concert and and
they all like fetch data from history
they perform the computation and they
put the data results back in its history
and then we have a simple job scheduler
that like just like keeps like running
running the computation so and because
of spot instance is actually
surprisingly cost-effective so we can we
can talk about more about this later so
so okay so this was pretty much the kind
of the tutorial I mean one thing that I
want to mention is this is an open
source project I mean there's a kind of
a small community on on the cheater so
feel free to join us there on this is
some like a list of ideas I actually
even mentioned the Python 3 here that
you could you could do with ldp all i
need's totally up to you this is open
source so I mean come with your own
ideas but I mean yeah they're like all
kinds of interesting things people have
started doing with it and I'm of course
like most importantly I mean like feel
free to use it in production
and yeah it actually works well for us
hopefully works well for you and I guess
that's it